when drew first interviewed me for her
show she asked who i was most starstruck
by
and i told the story about paul
mccartney you know
and you know it got me thinking about
meeting your idols you know there's
kind of three ways it can go one you
meet your favorite celebrity and
uh they're a monster and you go oh i
shouldn't have met my idol
uh two you meet your idol and they're
exactly what you want them to be and
actually uh you go this is amazing
which is like paul mccartney uh and then
third option is meet a celebrity
and that celebrity is drew barrymore and
she is so
stunning and warm and endearing
and and interested in you that you walk
away
thinking wow like wait drew barrymore
isn't just a celebrity i think
she's my best friend that's how i felt
when i
met drew for the first time i was on
saturday live drew was hosting
she was so creative and had a thousand
ideas
and was so giving and i remembered she
was going over two cards and someone was
trying to wig
and as i was happy some other person
came over and said drew i just want to
show you i have a tattoo of
you on my leg and she was like that is
so
oh that's beautiful but this happened in
like 10 seconds
of so can you imagine someone's life
that happens to you in in
totally multitask cool as cucumber just
like
yeah oh yeah and just honestly just i'll
never forget it and
luckily i got to be friends with
uh drew for from that moment on
until now i'm very very lucky um
she's one in a zillion no matter who you
are she makes you feel like the most
important person in the room
but uh don't just take my word for it
here's some other folks
who were just as starstruck by drew
one time i was starstruck was definitely
on the set of a movie that i did called
the stand-in where i had to play
opposite joe barrymore through barrymore
that's the time that i was starstruck
i've asked for a photo of two
celebrities in my entire life
um one mr barrymore and i won't say who
the other one was because that person
did not say yes
but yes drew barrymore i was starstruck
when i went here a moment i was star
struck was
uh the morning that i had to talk to
drew barrymore on her show
the first one is a time you've been star
struck this
happened she gets so excited i'm like
okay aaron don't overreact
it's really drew barrymore really
just happened oh gosh right now oh my
god it's hard to top this one are you
kidding me
yeah yeah right now for sure meeting
drew
on snl was you know i i was
i was completely starstruck and and very
shy to the point where i
i just i couldn't believe she was
talking to me it was a moment where
very early in my career really before my
career got started
um for drew to talk to me and be so nice
to me
in the hallway um yeah i'll never forget
that
one of the moments where i was the most
star struck to be honest with you
was right when where i was premiering
season one this is in 2017
we went to our first netflix party and
this is a god
honest truth drew barrymore walked in
and she was the first celebrity ever to
talk to myself in the cast
we have all talked about this moment
where drew was just so sweet so kind
i still have a group photo of all of us
and she was our very first celebrity to
ever say
good luck you're gonna make it you're
doing good in the world
and when you have people who you look up
to and honor saying that
you're gonna do good you hold tight to
that and so i still thank drew for that
moment and look at this
full circle here we are